thank you for to all of our panelists
and for everyone for joining today
looking forward to a really good
conversation around slack in education
and
really trying to facilitate a
conversation around
how people are using slack
for their
educational purposes and what questions
people might have in the group
so the format will be roughly we'll have
five or seven minutes that range of
presentation from each of our panelists
uh followed by a quick q a at the end of
each for for clarification or follow-up
and then a larger q a at the end of the
session
and again if you've got any questions
you can type those in the chat
um to start off today we've got stephen
helmerich um stefan's going to talk to
us about his experience using slack in
his anthropology course and stefan the
floor is yours
okay thank you aaron and
it's good to see everybody um
hi reese we've been emailing about ocw
sites today so
it's it's non-stop education um
i don't i don't i don't know why i was
asked to do this but i do use slack i
don't think that i have like anything
totally original i can tell you what i'm
doing and maybe that's useful
the presentation will therefore be like
two minutes
um
but i use slack in my anthropology
classrooms so we're thinking about kind
of a 40 to 50 person
classroom
and i asked students
to post comments on our readings prior
to coming to class
and i organized the slack channel into
you know the little channels that that
correspond to
the the sessions and so prior to each
thing people are asked to
meditate on you know what the readings
are maybe i have some structured
questions that i want them to answer and
that does a couple of things it makes
people come to class like super prepared
actually more prepared than
i'm used to them being which is quite
nice
um so they've already given things some
thought
and i'm able to go through those
comments and get a sense of what people
understood whether they may not have
understood what kinds of claims they
find interesting or alarming or
disturbing or reassuring
and so i make it i make a deadline that
you know things should be submitted by
like about three hours before class so
there's time for everyone to kind of
take a peek including importantly me
and i use those slack comments to do a
couple of things
not only to evaluate
you know what they're getting out of the
reading
but
if i have the time which is not always i
will go through my lecture notes for the
day and i will put call outs to things
that people said
in the slack you know on my notes itself
so they feel like when i'm doing a
lecture that
that they're included and that's a good
yeah i mean i think it's a good way to
kind of activate that kind of inclusion
um
[Music]
and i can then also call on people
um to to kind of say
to to do the live version
of their
premeditated
thought right which kind of lowers the
bar for speaking in important ways i
think particularly for folks who are
maybe shy or nervous
don't necessarily always know what to
say now they have something to say
so i think that's the general kind of
thing that i do one thing that
i did pretty early on which worked kind
of nicely was
you know i i really am wishy-washy about
my policy of whether electronics are
allowed in the classroom you know i kind
of like forgot to
to say don't bring your laptops pay
attention to me
or you know on the other hand you know
it's okay you can do some shopping but
um
but
since people do often have their
electronics available
what i've done sometimes is ask them to
open the slack page and pick out a
comment from another student and read it
and
offer some thoughts about what that
other student had to say and protect
particularly at the beginning of the
term that was super useful for also just
getting the students to know each other
right so oh kaylee says this where's
kaylee and the person will raise their
hand and we're all masked so you know
so it's a good way to kind of break the
ice and make people do some crosstalk
and yeah i make it pretty clear that you
are to find a comment in the slack that
you find interesting or that appeals to
you that you want to kind of surface
so i make it hard
to say you know i'm not saying like find
something that you think you disagree
with so there's
none of that right it's not it's not
smack it's slap it's slack um right so
it's
it's this thing to kind of generate a
kind of conviviality and so i found it
actually super useful both prior to
class and in the class itself and that
concludes my presentation
that was
awesome so thank you for for sharing
uh your story uh of using slack in
education it looks like cheryl might
have a question i just want to say
getting students for more prepared than
you ever expected is no small
accomplishment
that is a holy grail of sort so
i'm gonna give a second uh reaction
uh i actually wrote that down and put
little stars next to it so yes i i agree
that that is quite uh that's that's
amazing
i actually have a question just real
quickly um yeah so i was just curious
that when students are posting comments
about the readings you know before they
get to class have you seen them interact
um with each other's comments or did
they sort of save that for in class like
as you said you have them pull up a post
and um read it in class do you see them
interacting like before that with each
other in slack yes thank you very much
for that reminder that indeed does
happen and that's great right people
will say you know i really like what x y
and z person three steps ahead of me
said about this and i want to amplify
that or i wanna people actually have
done some disagreeing in a super
generative and productive way and very
nice you know like
i would like to disagree with this
because i see it somewhat differently
yeah nobody's
nobody's misbehaved but yes they
yes they do respond to each other and
that's also a good feature
great thank you
i actually had two questions go for it
yeah um so i just wanted to circle back
to
you're basically organizing these
threads of conversations with the
students based on readings and so i'm
i'm like i'm in my head in slack
thinking wait a second so you have a you
have a channel dedicated to class and
every like lecture one pre-reading is a
like the start of a thread and within
that everyone's applying to that thread
am i understanding that correctly you're
understanding it absolutely correctly
yes awesome i was like oh how okay um
and then i guess what i'm really curious
about is
are you is this incentivized and are
there points attached to students you
know responding on slack because
um
i'm just really curious how you're like
making sure everyone's really
contributing doing their part and if you
are taking points how are you gathering
that data
oh yeah thank you for that i totally
forgot about that part yes it is it is
toward their participation grade
um
so
yeah being the person who operates the
power levers i was invisible to myself
there for a moment um
yes it's a it's a it's part of their
kind of participation grade and they're
permitted
to miss three of them over the term
um
yeah so i guess what yeah so they
so you know if they don't speak the
entire session that's okay because
they've already spoken in slack right
um
so but yes i do make it part of the
participation
um
but i'm being super lenient about it
right now because there is still a
pandemic
and i think people are really
many of my students are um
being are very fragile
so um
you know don't tell them no you can tell
them but you know
like if they missed four it's like i
don't know yeah
so no i i i just following up on
on this quick exchange i think one of
the things that i think is really
important to highlight here is how
you're utilizing this to build the
community into the class right like i i
was struck by that like this is this is
a way to build the community as you
mentioned to sort of get to know one
another
to
to become aware of people's ideas and
their sharing and those pieces you know
i think as you start to build that
community it naturally can grow in some
ways that that sort of
you see
not having to quote unquote police it as
much because it is just part of the of
the ingrained part of the course and
that struck me as as part of the the
nature of the way you've sort of made
this happen in the class so thanks for
sharing that and i look forward to
coming back to some of those um i do
want to circle on to our next panel
presenter and
give the floor to monica vela who will
talk a little bit about her use of slack
for um for more on the course team side
in tas and sort of helping helping
communicate with them so go ahead monica
hello so i'm monica ramone um and so a
little background on who i am and why
i'm managing course teams on slack um i
am the 701 introductory biology gir
course coordinator or instructor
depending on who you ask which means i
do lots of things including
communicating and creating designs um
excuse me designing psets and exams and
helping coordinate our ta teams which
depending on the class can range from a
class about 70 to let's say on the
higher end
440 students
um and so that means i could yes
um so i could be working with anywhere
from four tas to 17 tas and
the communication
need
increases exponentially
especially past 10 people
and so something that i have started
doing and i think to great success is to
um basically make mandatory that our tas
join a private channel um that is
dedicated to our course team in order
for
myself and them to communicate
very very quickly
and um
this has been really great for a couple
of things but i've distilled it to
really sort of five five things so
anything you do on slack you can
technically do on email like it's not
it's not groundbreaking what i will say
though is the
benefit and the fun of slack that some
of trump's um the email experience is
that
um it's a much faster turnaround and a
lot lower of a barrier to reach out to
someone when you like write someone an
email you feel like it needs to at least
be a paragraph whereas i'm very
comfortable just like pinging my
tas with like an emoji or just like hey
what's going on like are you going to be
able to do grading um and they can react
to me or they could say oh sorry i
forgot or oh please remind me of things
and so just there's much faster
turnaround and i actually asked some of
my tas and something that's also very
nice is slack just feels a little less
formal
and that can actually really reduce sort
of the activation energy to communicate
because no one's like
like if i'm like replying to my tas with
a smiley face um they're like oh there's
a friendly human like this is fine i'll
ask a small question because it doesn't
hurt me
um and so i think that's been very nice
particularly for undergrad teas who
might sometimes be intimidated suddenly
reaching out to professors and
instructors and graduate tas
um
now something also very nice is as i
think stefan nicely pointed out you can
organize in your channel all these
different threads and so you can start a
thread in order to say hey any partial
credit for this piece set comment here
um and that's really quite easy to do
and you can have a lot of discussion
again that just feels more accessible
like communicating with 17 people total
it just feels easier to post it on a
slash channel rather than reply all on
an email thread
um
and something that's actually been very
a very nice use of this is when our tas
are grading assignments we often have
dedicated groups of tas who are
responsible for sort of making decisions
on partial credit and so we'll have
conversations amongst the tas as they're
grading on hey
pset whatever tas uh what should we do
about this sort of partial credit answer
what do you think and everybody has an
opportunity to weigh in and you can sort
of refer back to it and it's just um
it's really great for big group
communication
um
the other two things that are quite nice
is um for those of you who are unaware
you can schedule messages on slack which
is a godsend because i always remember
things always at like 11 35 at night i'm
just like why
um and so it's really really handy and
helpful for your teaching team when they
receive um sort of regularly scheduled
reminders about deadlines or please
remember to review this assessment or
don't forget we are releasing grades to
students at this time and all that can
be scheduled so you can just have that
ready to go and then set it and forget
it and it all magically happens for you
so from a coordinating perspective
it's
really really fabulous
and i highly recommend it
the other very fun thing is
you know you can't really update an
email message
but you can update slack messages and so
it's actually quite fun um when you ask
your teaching team to maybe vote on a
time or you know
choose a topic that you can actually
update your message as people start to
react or to say things and say oh eight
people have responded to the survey
awesome remaining four to go and when
everybody responds you can update your
message would be like 100 completion
congratulations and everybody can like
have little dancy emojis and is very
excited
um and so there's this sense of real
time and accountability that get can be
sort of infused into slack messaging
with a course team that just makes it
um
just very engaging it's just kind of fun
to see the emojis people use or sort of
the ways that people will react um
and the last thing i'll say is we we're
often using a lot of different digital
tools so i have a lot of google drive
documents and links and
our staff meeting notes are a shared
google doc and all of these can be
shared and it's very nice to have sort
of a central space for communication and
then a central space for files and
having them be able to
communicate um between each other has
been very very helpful and so the
feedback i've gotten um pretty
universally since i've implemented this
across different 701 course teams is
they're always like this this is really
amazing this is really helpful the
reminders are great it's so nice i feel
like i know people and i can reach out
whenever i have a question the team
feels accessible and so it's felt like a
great success and um i'm excited to
think about
slack now for the students
but i'm definitely a fan of slack for
the course team so
that's me
that's awesome monica thank you that was
uh that's it sounds awesome i want to
come and share dance emojis in the slack
channel that sounds great
there are many kinds the more rainbow
the better they're very happy um
yes right exactly um for those that
don't know there's also there's the
dancing tim the parrot or yeah the
beaver in the beaver yeah um there's all
sorts of ones um
uh any questions from from folks in the
who are joining us
i have a question
um i'm sitting here remembering all my
favorite emojis so thank you so much
monica for bringing that to my attention
um i was wondering though if um it
sounds like it's very effective for you
to communicate with your ta team do you
get
up
up up things coming do they you know
communicate to you is it a something
that they actually um in turn use yes
yes absolutely like i'll have um
you know we also use this for um you
know across the ta team you might have a
ta who suddenly says oh i've i've gotten
ill i need someone to cover my
recitation or someone says oh i had a
question in an office hour and i think
there's an error on the pset and so i i
definitely it's a two-way street um i
use it from my perspective as a way to
really like keep in touch and keep
ourselves coordinated but the tas are
definitely also speaking up and are
capable of sharing their opinions and or
um questions like with the entire team
and with myself
great thanks
so that's actually something i wanted to
follow up before we go to leo's question
in the chat
you know
are they
are they building a community amongst
themselves as well so is it really just
communication between you and them or
have they sort of start started to take
ownership of it themselves and and
answer one another rather than you
having to maybe be the voice of
answering everything all the time as
maybe the case in an email thread for
example
yeah so i've definitely um
i have a i have i'm thinking of a
favorite interaction from last semester
where
we had a small ta team so they were very
close and we had maybe one professor
also in our slack channel
and um this class covered
topics that were not very common um for
everybody to know about ecology and so
we often had these really great
discussions with the tas initiating
saying like
how do we demonstrate how do we
calculate how these two species are more
evolutionary closely related than the
other and there would be this long
exchange like at 6 00 pm at night where
the tas are going back and forth going i
thought about it this way and they're
like oh i thought about it this way and
then the professor at the end would
chime in and be like that is correct and
we would all you know be very excited
um i kind of lost my thread um but
basically i've definitely seen this kind
of exchange without me and that's also
happened around
um
even with partial credit that sometimes
i'll be out of commission for the
afternoon and i'll definitely come back
and see that my tas have been chatting
with each other about like no i'm pretty
sure this that doesn't count as full
credit they kind of missed this key
point here's what i would recommend and
the ta says oh thank you and i was not
involved
very good i do want to thank you for for
that and i think it sounds like that
just you know it's building that this
own sort of learning community of tas
and instructors which i think is great
um the question in the chat was you know
do you manage how do you manage to get
students to adopt it once and for all
like how do you how do you get that to
be the platform of choice versus still
maybe receiving emails or other
messaging or you know how do you
convince everybody that this is the
place that this happens
yeah um so one of the things we do in
the biology department specifically is
we have um instructor ta agreements
and it is inc it is very formal that i
say we are going to communicate through
slack
and then very early on even before the
semester starts i hound every single
human invite them to the mit biology
workspace
um and then confirm that they are in
fact receiving and able to respond to my
messages and that is the only way that i
will like that they can expect to
communicate with me and
um i haven't had anyone fight me um they
really are at a disadvantage if they're
not on the slack channel and um
most folks find it so helpful that and
i'm also very aggressive about hounding
people if they're not on it that i've
not had anybody
um
sort of not adopt slack
but i think it helps to be very official
about it and i do have to sometimes like
isntt has to get involved in order to
make sure they can actually sign on so
um there is an initial push but once
they're on they're on and then they find
it really helpful
awesome thank you and hopefully that
answers the the question
um michelle temasek wrote in the chat
you know this is something that they're
seeing in 801 and 802 with their grad
tas as well and it makes everybody want
to sort of do a better job and i think
that's right
that's the idea right is if you can
start to build this community of of
practitioners of educators that are
working with you uh that's that goes a
long way to sort of helping
normalize and and get better um better
work out of your tas and and more
effective instruction across the board
that's awesome
um so i want to be cognizant of time and
and move on to our final uh final uh
instructor panelist for today and then
we'll we'll circle on to one more um so
next up is tristan collins so tristan is
coming us from from the mathematics
department um the floor is yours thanks
for joining us hey thanks uh thanks for
the invitation um
so i should preface this with the fact
that i used slack during the uh let's
see
spring semester of 2020
is that right uh so
um or maybe it was
fall semester 20 yeah fall semester of
2020. so
um
everything was online so slack was used
uh not so much as a choice but as a
necessity
um so i used it in a class with
400 students
which is
uh
not really what slack is designed for
for 400 people but
um the idea was to have a place which
could function sort of like the
classroom so a place where students
could talk to each other they could
interact with tas it could interact with
me
and a place where i could sort of funnel
a lot of the course
stuff through so
for example office hours were sort of
started through slack so you can people
could post
their zoom links in slack
you could have question answer sessions
students could work together
um on problem sets this kind of thing so
it was really as an attempt to try to
create some version of the stuff that we
are used to in a regular classroom so
let me just show you i actually still
have my slack channel so i can um
i can show you what it looked like
how it was organized so when you have
400 students the organization becomes
kind of important
so this is the so it's now been broken
down but you can see it a little bit so
there was um
uh you can see here there's a
recitations panel so before there was a
a slack chat for each different
recitation so recitations like small
group groups
only students from each recitation were
able to access those slack channels as
well as their ta
there were study rooms which took a
little bit of
trial and error but what uh this
originally they were intended to just be
places where students could interact
with each other but then it became clear
that
that it was more
efficient in some way to organize them
into so each room was dedicated to a
problem on each problem set so if each
problems that had seven problems there
was a problem uh study room for problem
one a study room from problem two et
cetera where students could go and
ask questions answer other people's
questions talk to the tas about
specific
questions
there's an announcement
there's an announcements panel which was
just for me to broadcast announcements
about the course about exams or homework
assignments well there are no exams but
homework
assignments due dates that kind of stuff
and a main hall which was just for sort
of general chat so
main hall was accessible to everyone so
were the study rooms announcements was
just staff only and then there was also
a staff channel which i've now
deleted but that was um
that was just used for coordinating
between me and the tas to
discuss things like grading sort of what
uh what uh like what monica was talking
about so
very similar
um
and it was actually so i would say um
it was quite popular i think a lot of
students liked it not everybody i didn't
make it mandatory to use it that kind of
thing is
hard to implement with 400 students
um
but it was quite popular people use it i
think that people who did use it got a
lot more out of the class than the
people who didn't
it was great because it sort of
you know it makes it uh
it really lowers the barrier for
students to approach
me or the other tas in the class with
questions and it also made it possible
for them to talk to each other you know
in a in a digital education you know
when you're when everything's online
um i think that's the thing that
students miss the most
um and certainly there are a lot of
students who you know some students in
the class who really did the work of a
ta but
but but maybe from a less imposing point
of view so they really helped their
classmates and
and there were some really great uh i
think very productive discussions on
there um
and it was a bit you know there was also
some social aspects students getting to
talk to each other and
um if you remember that was the fall
2020 was also the presidential elections
there was a lot of uh
emotional support
happening within the 1803 slack
slack channel so
um
so all in all i would say it was a big
big success the only the only um slight
complication is that slack competes a
bit with piazza when it comes to
education stuff
and i think that was a little bit hard
to explain to students we use both i
think piazza is very good for very
formal sort of well-posed questions
and less good for discussion
um
i didn't really have a rigid policy
about where one should be used versus
the other but i think there were some
students who
felt like there was some common overlap
between the two
um
i don't think either one replaces the
other
um but definitely that was a little bit
of
that was maybe the part that was most
difficult to convince students was that
they should be using both and not just
one or the other
um yeah so anyways i'll uh in my
presentation there
that was great thank you tristan i'll
give a minute for folks that want to ask
some some questions made with tristan
and
before we move on to our final panelist
i have a quick question yeah go for it
um
so tristan when you had the slack
channel for your students was this
through the canvas integration for slack
like it was through the lms because i
can't imagine you having to invite
students oh no yeah i had to i had to
invite 400 students individually yeah
it was it was one pretty painful day
um
or afternoon i think the the most
painful part was that they all had to be
invited to their own recitation channels
as well so it wasn't like i was inviting
everyone to one slack channel
but yeah it took me uh it took me
a while to do that and then of course as
at the beginning of the term when
there's um
people dropping the course or joining
the course then you have to also
i mean it's sort of continual but
um i would say once the bulk of the 400
people was done it was not such a big
deal to maintain as the
semester went on but yeah that was um
unfortunately slack does not have a
great way to add 400 students or 400
people to a slack channel all at once
so one of the upsides this may have been
before the full integration was in place
but now one of the one of the upsides is
that through the slack integration with
canvas we can actually pair people
directly in so from your roster in
canvas we can populate a single channel
with all of the folks that are on your
roster in canada that's amazing into one
thing
so
a full day
yeah so
hopefully that encourages uh continual
use down the line and that it lowers
that barrier and you can you can
activate that that integration and it
will it will sync those students into
that channel
so
good news on that front yeah i think i
did have some conversations with the
people at slack about how i should do
this and they said
best of luck to you so maybe they they
went ahead and fixed that issue
yeah we we think we've got that one
squared away with the the canvas and lti
so
some folks have actually used that this
term to some success i think
other questions
um so uh we'll
circle back and and continue the
conversation in a moment but i want to
turn to our final panelist
um uh the learning engineer actually on
uh open learning residential's team uh
lauren tatino um has been sort of
checking out all sorts of different uses
of slack and how people have been been
using it broadly and
want to share a few points with with the
group about what she's sort of
discovered along the way and hopefully
facilitate even some some more
conversations about uses so lauren i'll
hand it over to you
sure thanks aaron and thank you to our
three great panelists for sharing your
experiences with slack
and so what i'm going to do is share a
few more
potential use cases for how you can use
slack for teaching and learning
and you'll actually see some of them
tristan just touched on actually as well
and some of them might be
new and different from the examples we
heard today but um these are just a few
ways that i've from seeing how others
are using slack at mit just a few that
i've brought up here
one is for student group work or group
projects that are maybe are longer term
and last
for a longer chunk of the semester
and some of the slack features that
really help with this are having private
channels for each group kind of like
having a
channel for each recitation section um
the file sharing which monica touched on
is also really helpful for groups who
are constantly sharing or working on the
same documents um and even just the
nature of threaded discussions and how
that's a big feature of slack that's
great for tracking progress over time um
like i said especially if it's like a
longer term kind of thing
um recitation sections tristan had
touched on that one already um again
with using the private channels feature
um and something like channel search too
is really helpful in a case where
students are asking a lot of questions
because you can maybe search for some
keywords and see if your question's
already been asked before and sort of um
look back and see if you can get even
more answers
um
i've also seen it used in a more
informal way for like informal
conversation that community building
aspect that aaron's talked about before
and just other ways to sort of apply
content that you're working with in the
in your course
so again using public channels and the
threaded nature of discussions in slack
for example you could have a channel
that's dedicated to like talking about
news or current events and the ways that
that those articles relate to course
content
or just other just a space for students
to talk about other ways that the the
course content is applying to their
lives
um alternative or supplement to office
hours and they're interested also to
touch briefly on on the idea of posting
office hours information
that's something that like a ta can
monitor for example and use it to do
everything from posting logistical
information like when and where in
person office hours is happening but a
channel could also be used to um you
know have a dedicated time period where
the ta is answering questions from
students
just so they don't have to wait for you
know the one one or two times that
there's an in-person office hour session
and then lastly i think a lot of people
use slack for this just course
communications and announcements um you
know a lot of people just use the
default general channel that's
automatically part of your slack
workspace when it's set up um but the
big thing here and again monica touched
on the idea of like norm setting and
really encouraging everyone to like
stick to a communication method i think
if you were if you wanted students um
and or your course team to really use
slack for contacting people or asking
questions things like that um you just
have to set that norm that you know hey
everyone we're going to use slack
instead of email or instead of canvas
announcements um or if you're using more
than one like again just make sure
you're establishing that at the
beginning of the beginning of the course
and um
yeah these are just a few ways we've
seen uh being used at mit and of course
this is on top of the great examples we
heard from our panelists um so feel free
to ask any questions
do you have any
thank you
thanks lauren and so i there's a couple
of things that i've written down in
terms of questions that i wanted
to ask the panelists before before we
jump in and and one of them is something
we haven't touched on yet but the
question is like what do you do at the
end of the term
so
you know when you know in monica's cases
you know there's there can be some
really rich and great
materials that are sort of
historical documents of like oh yeah we
don't want to do that again or maybe you
know we always want to make sure that
problem set one is is dealing with this
thing you know how do you deal with
that you know is it just adding the new
tas to the old channel so that it's so
searchable
um i'm you know and and on the other
side you know tristan i'm curious like
what might that look like if you were to
try to reuse this again with a course
you know would it just be repopulating a
new course with with new materials i'm
just curious how people have thought
about this or worked through some of
some of those ideas
um well maybe i i can uh start as i show
i showed you my deleted slack
channel so i tried to um
pass it along to the person who was
teaching the the same course in the
spring semester of
um
which they didn't end up using it but i
thought i mean because there's so much
student content on there i didn't feel
comfortable
leaving that there for for uh posterity
or whatever so i i ended up just uh
deleting all the messages and removing
everyone from the channel
but i think um
um
yeah that's i mean that's just one of
those things i wasn't sure how to
navigate that in a way that assured
everybody's privacy in a in a way that i
felt comfortable with so
yeah i guess just to jump on that i have
i'm about to go into my second year of
instructing and so i'm about to reach
this point where i i ask do i
revive the old
spring 2020 channel for spring 2021
and i think my
my instinct is to not just because i
unless i had buy-in from every single
person in that channel prior i'm kind of
inclined to keep that as it was what it
was that course team and
that um
if there's anything that was really
important to capture from those
conversations my inclination is to leave
that channel because i can still search
it
um but to create a channel for every new
course team and i may actually
ultimately do what tristan said and
delete
things um for now i think i'll create
new until i realize that's not viable
over a long period of time but i try to
capture useful information um in other
documents that
can be stored like google docs that can
also be shared with like
new generations of course teams so
that's sort of what i'm both thinking
and um still debating
awesome thanks for sort of following up
with that um so you know now's the time
we've got a little bit of time left i
want to open it up for questions that
the the group may have if you just want
to unmute yourself and ask
if you want to type it in the chat
things you're interested in hearing more
about
from jason for everyone um do you wish
that slack did anything better
for your courses
there go track participant
right track participation track
participants
yeah that's a good question
it's a hard one
yeah i mean tracking purchase i mean i
know it does track participation sort of
on mass
having maybe
better
sort of more resolved data would
probably be useful to see who's
who's participating and who's not
especially for large groups
i wish that it
supported
so in matthews
latex a lot which is a typesetting
program i wish that it supported latex
i had a ta who was very uh who was good
with computers who wrote a
a bot that could compile latex on on
slack but it was not super reliable and
so yeah some more support for a sort of
scientific type setting and slack would
be super useful
it's a really good one and one that
we've definitely heard before for for
sure uh on a number of fronts with a
number of different platforms as well
beyond slack as well um really
interesting question as well in there
you know how do you decide whether a
course warrants an entire slack
workspace or just a channel
i'll jump in a little bit and i think i
think a lot of it also depends on this
this really is heavily dependent on the
size of the course
because as you know tristan pointed out
you know manually adding 400 students
you know to that workspace was
challenging if you can auto link it with
your with your canvas roster okay that
that's at least easier and that's a
workspace right if you decided to use a
channel you would at that point would
probably have to add everyone
individually
so i think it just depends on on the
unique aspects of of the course and what
you're deciding you want to use with it
also comes down to functionality you
know within a channel
you know if you want to have multiple
channels like tristan give that example
of like there were multiple channels in
that workspace for different purposes
um
that would that would be a really
interesting you know you would want to
have a workspace for that rather than
just a bunch of channels that you have
to keep adding everybody to i think
did that resonate with folks or
anything i may have missed there
yeah i think um i mean for me i don't
want to monopolize so somebody should
tell me to stop but um for me i think
the
i wanted to have um
to organize the discussion i think
uh to have places where certain types of
discussion were encouraged other places
where
because otherwise i think if you are
mixing too much the sort of
mechanical parts of the class the
scientific parts of the class and the
social parts of the class then it's just
it would just be um
a bit of a mess so i think it was i
think i liked having a workspace with
different channels to sort of
compartmentalize the various parts of
the experience with people
very good yeah so lauren
followed up on the question thank you
tristan uh lauren chimed in and asked
you know do does anybody has anybody
looked at the
analytics
for engagement stats has it been helpful
to anyone
i'm not excited about this right now
i'm gonna go look
we've done our job we've we've triggered
a new thing that has to
that has to be followed so yeah and and
tristan am i right that it's mostly
compiled like it's aggregate across
users is that did i get that
right yeah i mean it just tells you how
many people interact with slack in a
week or something like that so if
there's 400 people it'll tell you that i
mean you can see little charts about
engagement and show say you know any
given week maybe 170 people
engaged and
70 posted or something but it doesn't
tell you
who
but yeah that was i mean that was useful
enough to get a sense of whether all the
work was really worth it or whether
there i was just doing a lot of work for
20 people to
chat with each other
yeah and i actually think this is
something that circle it circles back to
another sort of question
i think for each of you you know monica
and interesting it's a little bit
different because one is with students
one is with sort of the the course team
but inevitably there's there's got to be
ebbs and flows in usage right so you
know there are going to be times
inevitably where i would suspect man
everyone is using this all the time
maybe it's a piece that is due maybe
it's a you're in the middle of grading
and there are other times where
there's nothing to be posted and it's
weird because you're like wait a second
is this thing on like is this working um
and so
i guess the the question coming out of
that is like
um
how do you manage engagement
expectations with each of those groups
and sort of
also setting your own expectations for
when it's okay to have those ebbs and
flows when it's you know you're not
constantly pushing to have to engage
with
i think that may be a concern for some
right is like do i have to constantly be
on slack every second of every day
if i'm using it this way
um yeah i don't have a good uh good
answer for that i was i did find that i
was on slack a lot but it actually
didn't bother me i mean it's easier to
engage with slack on your phone or
whatever than it is to write an email or
something so it does i mean like monica
monica was saying um it does encourage
sort of
less formal interactions which is
uh lowers the
pressure i think a little bit
um but yeah i think and there were
certainly epson flows the night before
pset was due
user ship would spike and over
thanksgiving nobody used slack so
um
but yeah i mean i didn't really have a
policy about
how much i expected people to use it
so i didn't really
worry too much about that but i think it
is a sister's concern
yeah i can comment from the course teen
perspective most folks i mean i'm i'm a
strong encourager of boundary setting
and
making notifications happen if you want
if you're compulsive and can't help
yourself from checking everything
because it's addictive which
um and uh i can't turn notifications off
because i just can't yet so i i'm always
checking my slack stuff um and um
absurdly responsive which i just take as
a point of pride
um but i think
i haven't done anything formal i think a
reasonable expectation is if i slack
someone on my course team and like it
takes them over 48 hours to respond then
i shoot them a slack and an email and
say hey you know i get it if you're busy
but like two days is a lot and i i
expect this to be a good so it's a
real-time communication can you tell me
what's going on
um and sometimes it's just that they're
delinquent or they don't have a good
setup for slack communication they're
like signing on to you know i don't know
the like browser version and they don't
have something downloaded on their phone
or on their computer and so sometimes
it's just
a technical formality and sometimes
they've just been ignoring me or haven't
sent notifications in which case they're
like i'm very sorry
i will change my notifications so great
that is very nice thank you but that
hasn't been very frequent and i think
again from a course team perspective
everyone's pretty dedicated and wants to
do a good job and so very few people are
purposely trying to ignore you on slack
in in my context
perfect thank you i want to be cognizant
of time and so i know there's one more
question and we're going to get to it if
we if you folks can stick around but if
you've got to jump off we sort of
understand it's it's that time of day
um so thank you to
me let this be my formal thank you to
all of our panelists and
people who contributed with questions
and ideas and coming and being part of
the conversation um if you need to jump
off i understand i want to betsy
ask the question of you know how might
slack feel from a student's perspective
in other words you know how does it feel
if
all of their courses are using slack
does that feel
potentially overwhelming maybe that's a
really good question i wonder
um
i wonder
i wonder that's that's a really great
question does anybody have any thoughts
feedback
um
yeah i can't comment because i used it
exclusively with my course team so i
can't answer that one but perhaps
tristan
um
i mean i think
when
i was using it most of my students
did not have any other classes using
slack so i did sort of didn't have to
worry about that too much but yeah i can
imagine from uh
well i mean on the other hand i mean all
the students use piazza for every class
and they don't seem to worry about that
too much so i
yeah i'm not sure i mean
yeah i'm not i don't really i'm not sure
how they would feel but at the time i
mean
um
they didn't seem
to worry about it too much they seem to
like it for the most part although
that's it's a bit of a self-selecting
group but the people who used it were
the ones who liked it so
i can't say for sure
no i i think that's it's it's something
to consider i also think it's you know
back to what both what all of the
panelists have said is like also about
how you build the community of of use
around like what is the purpose of it
right like if you're really setting it
up in an authentic way much like we've
heard from the panelists where it's it
is part of the class it's sort of
integrated and and being utilized
sort of in these purposeful ways i i
feel like that might feel a lot more
authentic and students are you know and
course teams are much more likely to
want to engage at that point than if it
sort of
feels just like this is something it's
busy work i'm being forced to post these
things not because we're going to use
them or not because we're going to
engage with them but simply so that you
can check a box that i engaged right
like i think those have very different
feels for students and so the more
authentic you can
uh
the more ways you can foster authentic
engagement the better the the sort of
outcomes are likely to be
um
all right uh i noticed one more
oh a couple of things so you know
jason asked the question um
do you feel a slack increased engagement
um compared to maybe more or other
methods just i guess that's maybe a
question for you i know it's sort of
it's a
it's not the perfect one to one because
it it happened sort of during remote
times but but you know i think you
mentioned that you felt like it had a
pretty positive impact and if you maybe
follow that up a little bit
yeah i think um
yeah i haven't tried using slack during
a sort of quasi-quasi-post-pandemic
world so i can't say
um
i mean maybe i'll try i'm teaching in
the same course actually this spring so
maybe i'll try to use it then and see
how it goes um
but i would say that um
you know my experience with
uh with with teaching this big class in
fall 2020 was that the without slack
students would have basically had piazza
um
lectures were totally
hopeless as far as students interacting
with each other even when i tried to
make small groups happen
uh during lectures um people would just
go into their into their small group
room and sit quietly with their screens
off on mute
it wasn't particular i mean it's just
hard to make um
engagement happen and then the way that
students would interact with each other
is they'd either they'd just talk to
their friends that they had in the class
or to friends they had who had taken the
class previously or whatever so it was
very you know there was almost no
interaction between students um
outside of slack and i think slack was
very useful in um
in getting students to talk to each
other who maybe wouldn't otherwise have
talked to each other so i i think it was
um
versus doing nothing in the in the
remote setting i think it was very
positive whether or not in a
in a situation where there is in-person
classes whether it will have any impact
i yeah it's hard to say i'm not sure
and that and i think uh um
it's a little unfortunate that stefan
had to step out to go teach because i
think his experience this term sort of
reflects a little bit of that that move
towards uh you know utilizing it to
bring people back into the classroom
like the way he sort of set that up to
to be the the pre-class activity that
leverages and is the is the entry point
into the communication in the classroom
really seems to strengthen that
relationship so that oh if i know if if
he's calling out and referencing people
in there and i've got really specific
questions that maybe if i post that it's
going to get addressed or i'm going to
get to engage with other people who have
different ideas you know it starts to
again foster that real authentic
engagement more so than sort of
just i have to post because that's what
the syllabus says
um we are unfortunately at time i i know
uh it went by quickly and it was a great
conversation and i hope everyone found
it
valuable
i enjoyed it it was a lot of fun so
again a huge thank you to to our
panelists for volunteering to share
their stories of using slack
and you know if you've got more
questions or comments or ideas or want
to share more of your own stories um
please reach out to anybody in our
office whether that be molly myself
lauren um cheryl barnes who was on the
call and then had to run our director
we look forward to hearing more from
sort of everybody along the way so thank
you everybody and uh best of luck as we
wrap up the term and and head to the
holiday break
bye everyone